what the [ __ ] is going on i
like to party jesus honey from podcast
one
this is unwaxed get in loser we're going
shopping with sophia and sistine
stallone
we just become best friends yup
hi everyone welcome back to unwaxed uh
this is sophia if you're new here
welcome if you are curry welcome back i
can't get that done for the life of me
guys this is going to be a new episode
one without video yeah it's a little bit
different if you guys can't already tell
by the probably poor sound quality
coming from our end of things
we are shooting in our living room right
now because if you've watched the news
the world is shut down yet again
california once again we cannot go to
restaurants
nail salons including our studio
so this is kind of a trial run for us
this episode we're going to do no video
but next week's episode we're going to
attempt video
coming to you live from our living room
it's going to look
trash but we're going to try our best
you know i actually have a little bit of
ptsd right now
from shooting in here why because we
were so bad
when we first did this in here do you
ever used to fight someone we told the
story
that we used to just want to kill each
other because it just didn't feel right
like the studio i feel like when we're
in the studio it feels real legitimate
and i can get my professional face on
but
right now i'm looking at sophia with no
makeup i'm wearing a coors
shirt and cesine's wearing a leopard
tank top i'm rocking no bra
no bra yeah baby the bags welcome
hanging looking out 100 of the time
again with this episode we're going to
do something a little bit different
we're going to introduce our guest
now because i'm afraid that if we don't
bring her on soon
she's going to go back into hibernation
and the deep slumber that i
summoned her from this morning you guys
actually i'm going to ask you right now
do you realize how many people have
actually been requesting you to be on
the show
thank you guys wait seriously wait can
we just pause for a second
scarlett that did not sound like your
normal voice scott let's run that back
let's use a human voice this time
i'm going to ask you again ready here we
go get me off now
a lot of people actually have been
asking for you to be on the show
which is exciting yep thank you guys how
does that make you feel
makes me feel very loved you know i'm
kind of sad that we're not doing it
in the studio where you can see my face
but
well bummer i think i think you guys did
this for a reason
so i think i should introduce you
properly like i do all of my guests
because you're not that special
all right so i'm gonna give you you're
horrible
i'm gonna give you a proper introduction
the guests we have booked today
i'm going to introduce right now she has
actually been really nervous to do this
show
and we've asked her for a while and
that's okay
a hundred times a day and she goes
sorry i'm busy i'm doing kind of just
sorry
boyfriend we'll get into that we'll get
into that she is the baby of the family
despite looking
much older than you guys she is a
sasquatch if you didn't know
she has been inherently cool since
leaving the womb
and somehow skipped the awkward phase of
her teen years we have
scarlett stallone
why do you guys greet me like this every
time i get coffee in the morning and see
you guys down there because
usually whenever we like see each other
in the morning sistine does not even
look at me she just grunts
and then sophia is like good morning
everybody when she wakes up whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa i am not a morning person
that does not make me a brat
and i'm sure 50 of the world can agree
wait can i say scott you're not a
morning person either oh absolutely not
you both are the worst but you know what
i kind of skipped the morning phase
because i sleep in however you guys are
up at like 6 a.m for some oh unknown
this reminds me of the time when sister
and i would drive to school and i'm a
morning person i am
up talking at 6 00 a.m and i would drive
her and i would be talking her ear off
and cece would start just screaming at
me or ignoring me and i would get so
frustrated i'm sure some people out
there can relate
to me when it's 6 45 and you woke up at
maybe
5 30 you don't want to have a full-blown
energetic conversation before you've had
a cup of coffee sofia sorry
i remember like you guys would come home
so mad at each other
every day of high school and i would be
in like 8th grade 7th grade whatever
and you guys would both like look at me
and like pull one of you each of you
like pulled me into another room and
then
she would be like sophie was so annoying
this morning we got into another fight
and then
got a party and then sophia comes to me
and she was like i'm so nice to her
she's just so mean it's so true i'm like
i don't know i'm just asking how she is
and she tells me to shut up
so we actually wanted to bring on
scarlet for our weekly updates because
normally we don't have a guest to do
this with but yeah it's fun to have a
little info
on the great backup yeah we're gonna
have you kind of throw in some yeah
well you're not a backup we always
wanted you
a week into december and we're talking
about thanksgiving still if you guys
listen to the last episode
um you'll understand what this joke
means
so if you didn't kill anyone this year
or almost kill anyone
wait did you already say the story about
sophia yeah how i almost called an nfl
player
yeah yeah and actually people in the
comments are guessing the player
no yeah but no one's guessed it
correctly don't say that now
um so now that thanksgiving's over i
honestly hate this time of the year
because i feel like so many events are
just
clustered into one time frame now it's
christmas coming up
and there's nothing more stressful to me
and maybe you guys can agree
christmas shopping for your parents
absolutely
terrible nothing will please you i
haven't bought anything for them
what do you get your parents so hard the
first week of december i was done with
both of you i don't know exactly
everything's coming in on time but mom
and dad i was like what do they not have
they're twice their age they've had
everything they've done
everything and that's the problem so
it's like with the budget that we have
to spend
just like what can we get them that's
like you know when you're giving someone
is like the 40
gift limit like that's me right now i'm
like what can i get mom for 40.
like nothing so i said the funny thing
is i'm more of the person you guys both
know this that likes to do sentimental
things because i'm like oh okay maybe if
i do like a photo collage or write a
really nice but
i've done all that i've exhausted all
those ideas so now i'm like
what do they need like a like a necklace
holder like what what can i
make up sophia last year she says i buy
experiences
not presents so last year for christmas
i look under the tree and i see some
envelope i'm like why is this a dress
she was so good about it so this is what
it's a big gummy
it was a great gift by the way i opened
an envelope
it's from sofia and it's a pizza making
class
and i thought that was so cute but it
wasn't until like the end of january
that we could have done it so my gift
took some
time to get but your experiences are
good but the problem is
you can't do that anymore no no every
year i never get sophia a good gift
it's always something better she got you
know you got me last year that i still
wear all the time she got me
men's uh pants or like capri pants what
are the ones to the knees at basketball
shorts
it's from urban outfitters yeah she got
me men's clothes
no she also got you a pair of boxers
with your face printed on the ass
it was just looking like you're coming
through the hole
oh yeah she got me yeah yeah that looks
like my face is peeking out of the ass
so if you guys know because it's also
like one of those like really like
intense like sexy fights
i was going through your old closet and
like i see my gag
gift like in the back back back of your
like sock
no but whenever you're wearing them let
me tell you i checked my ass out
all the time i'm like sophia what do you
think what's happening back there
what's poppin um so if you guys actually
could
shoot over some ideas that you're
getting for your parents that you can
help assist us out over here that would
be really nice
in other news i would like to make a
very special announcement
about me ah thank you
i try to do a work drumroll with one
hand i have joined
hinge yes it's our daily friday night
routine looking at
christine has graduated from the elite
kind of group in harariah yeah to now
let me
set the boys of hinge i'm gonna paint a
picture for y'all
i was on raya from what i've told you
guys it was a disaster
didn't get any dates sophia thrived i
skyrocketed so one saturday night
sophia says let's drink i say let's do
it we're drinking tequila feeling good
having fun and my cousin goes
what about hinge and i said what hinge
i didn't understand it because you know
some day dating apps are about girls
asking guys guys asking
i didn't understand the only thing i
knew about it was the funny questions
that you get asked
i didn't even know that yeah which we'll
we'll talk about um
so immediately as they're discussing it
i've downloaded signed up and uploaded
my profile within
35 seconds guys i respect the scene so
much because i'm definitely not the
person to just
jump right off the bat going into a
dating app without even thinking cecine
was like yep i'm doing it downloading
maybe the alcohol played a role in my
substantial role in it but
profile is made it was really funny
because you how it works is they give
you a bunch of prompts and then you get
to answer
three questions just to sort of show
your personality and
my approach is okay what's the funniest
thing that i could possibly come up with
so i just seem super
like cool and quirky and like so
christine what did you
say on your profile so there was one
question that said
believe it or not i blank and the first
thing i thought of was
swallow to be not on purpose and
that one's a winner because every guy
just responds to that like why would you
swell i would hope you not swallow a bee
on purpose
right so that one's good but i have to
say the guys on hinge
are so assertive and want to start
conversation and aren't afraid of
sliding in your
inbox first which i so appreciate
but what i found was so funny about
hinge is that
a lot of the people i matched with on
raya were also unhinged i was like oh
round two we're gonna see each other
again what are we gonna do but what i
thought was
so funny is what we've been doing since
i've had this hinge profile is
not only do i consult with sophia and
scarlett before i message or match
anyone
back up when we say consult sistine air
plays
her matches on screen yeah now we're
getting really unwashed
and this one to see matt put some like
three
this has been my most entertaining thing
so if you guys think that you are
matching with justice no you're matching
with sistine
scarlett and sophia and sometimes mom
and dad and sometimes oh yeah we have
had mom and dad
this is what we'll do we will airplay my
phone
to the tv so it's literally like a live
dating show
and so everyone will be like yes to this
person swipe no to this person well it's
also good if we
all like you it means that you have the
qualities of being
funny good personality good looks
and all around probably look like you
have a good job so i have to say
if you're listening and i've matched you
all five family members
approved and what i thought was so funny
is while we were airplaying at one of
the days
oh my gosh oh i know what you're gonna
say
so like i said before there's a few
repeats from mariah that have been on
hinge so i'm just scrolling about my
hinge page everyone's watching we're all
having a good time
and i see one of the guys that sophia
had gone out on a few dates with and if
you go back to
episode 2 with clint coley advice from a
[ __ ] boy go listen if you haven't
we talked about sofia seeing this
athlete he comes up on my hinge
we were like oh my god that's so funny
we said no obviously right away
the very next i am not exaggerating when
i say the very next profile to come
up from the hundreds of thousands of
profiles on hinge
the one that comes up is mr bamboozle
mr bamboozle if you don't know that
story time again go back it was when i
showed up on sofia's date and the guy
said i bamboozled her
then he pops up i sound like the biggest
oh
god and then though to make matters
worse hinge
matches you with the person based on
compatibility
and i got matched with mr bamboozle
so not only did the steve say no
initially when she saw him on the
profile i messaged him hinge
forced his profile back on the seats are
you
sure you guys seem like a great match
how funny would it be if i messaged him
like
i feel bamboozled honestly i actually
think it'd be really funny if you did
that
you are the youngest you're the baby
obviously mom and dad i feel like anna
sophia can agree with me they put a lot
of rules on us when we were growing up
which i'm really grateful for now
because we never were bad kids we never
snuck out but it dropped
me the hell off when i was well yeah of
course but scarlett do you think that
you had an easier time with less rules
or do you think they were just as strict
as
on you i think as dad got older
i think that he began to like go to bed
earlier
not caring like he's just he takes a lot
of naps now he got old and sleepy
now i think he like he still cares
because i mean every time i go out or
anything he's like where are you going
where are you going like blah blah blah
but
i don't think i had it as hard as you
guys because he didn't take
he didn't pass out i would also like to
mention that
because sophia and i were sort of doing
everything together at the same time
you're lucky that you have two older
sisters that have already been there
done that so we are here
to you know get you out get you home
i know you guys are out there
but i did pull some strings for you
sometimes hey we all pull strings for
everything
who pulled strings from me what are you
two talking about you don't get yourself
in a pickle
i do i know and then i i
sometimes save you so you can get away
with more
oh 100 yeah yeah because i got you guys
to help me
yeah because i'll be honest this one who
sounds like she's a little angel
is a little devil a little rebel this
girl is the rule breaker of the family
i'm not even kidding you when she was
growing up
she never did anything i would hate to
have me as a child you guys i would
absolutely hate it
no that's not true you're very fun but
you're a contrarian
you tell her not to do something she'll
do it but
now now we've kind of realized that we
have to tell her to do something
and then she won't do it so then we get
what we want you have to tell her the
opposite of what you're going to do
yeah it's like it's like solving me is
like taking the hardest math test of
your life like you kind of
because i feel like we should tell some
of the stories from when you were
younger like some crazy [ __ ] they used
to do
oh okay i think um so
i'm gonna say like really short one time
i cut my hair with my dad's cigar
cutters
like two like to the point i was
literally bald and i think i was about
10 or something and cut my hair so short
walk into the room my mom screams bloody
murder and she's like what did you do
and i go the coyotes attacked me and the
kindest part is scarlet actually
not only did she cut her hair off and it
looks like someone put a lawnmower on
the top of her head
she stuffed all of the hair into the air
vent so when the air turned on it was
like snowing snowing hair
and then i used to um clog all the
toilets in the house
flush one everything would like go up
why would you do that like what was
going on
i i don't know that's what i mean i
would hate to have me as a child
and then the third thing was like i got
like tubs of yogurt because my dad used
to eat
so much yogurt for some reason he had a
face and
we just took the top i just took tubs
and tubs of it and just
splattered all over the kitchen and then
i would strip down naked and slide all
over the kitchen
aside from being weird you were also one
of the funniest people and i always said
this growing up that you were going to
be some sort of
talk show host stand of course i always
thought that too she was just so
unapologetically yourself i feel like
if we can be unwaxed um i feel like when
you were
a freshman sophomore year you were in
high school and you were you sort of
like lost
your your spark a little bit and you
were upset and then you were able to
transfer schools and your whole life
sort of just like reset and you were
yourself again and you were happy
i want to talk about a little bit how
when you started a new high school
how did that affect you like emotionally
and friend wise like what did you go
through then
i think that um i think that with me
like
dealing with groups and stuff and moving
around was
very difficult because i don't know like
we're
obviously we were all treated kind of
differently in our groups
like i was picked on a lot
growing up as well as you guys too like
we we
all were like i had i don't want to just
like talk we're talking about you
nobody i know but we all i know that we
won't get like
we can make it
i mean if this sounds like a surprise or
not massively bullied
and i think that people assume that it
is really easy for us to
like make friends and go throughout high
school but you know
with the name being as amazing as it is
and it holds a lot of
incredible weight and honor it
has a lot of preconceived notions that
come along with it and i think that
all three of us have experienced people
rejecting us or assuming things or
talking about us and
you know unfortunately a lot of pressure
yeah and unfortunately it's a lot of
pressure like every high school like
i was so nervous to start my new high
school because like everyone
already knows me everyone already knows
what they think they already they think
they know who you are and then that's by
the way
same thing with college i remember going
in and everyone
thought that personally for me and this
is probably the same for you two
they knew exactly who we were they're
like oh they're gonna be spoiled or loud
or party girls or whatever but we end up
being like
the complete everyone yeah everyone
already like i don't identifies us
and not even knowing who we are um so
one of the times i'll
this is i think the basis of what
everyone should just take off of is
if you are not happy where you are
whether that's
a high school you don't love or a friend
group you're not loving or a college you
don't love
change it yeah you can get out make a
decision and if you can't let's just say
physically leave the high school
you have the power to change your friend
group you have the power
to get rid of those people or get rid of
that environment totally great
i'd rather be alone than being a toxic
friend sophia how many times did we
switch schools oh my god you guys
we think every two years i i switched i
went to
my elementary school then i went to
another one
and then i went to a different height
two different high schools i think i
went to at least six different
schools always the new kid yeah in the
school which honestly i loved because i
think i was crippling
shy girl like it was really bad yeah but
i have to say that i totally agree with
what you're saying
if your environment feels like it's you
know you're falling in quicksand and
you're suffocating and you feel like you
can't get out of this like
dark hole of emotion that you're in you
you can
and once you change the environment like
when scarlett switched
from her sophomore to junior year at a
different school i mean
it was like the girl that we loved
growing up came back
tenfold i want to transition a little
bit because you are 18.
and you are a senior which is like so
exciting because you're applying to
colleges and you're
doing that whole house like the worst
time right now well english i just
thought about something about college
that just reminded me about scarlet
scarlet do you want to tell everybody
what kind of college type photo you used
to have on your iphone screen
saver oh baby she's putting her on blast
yeah i think we should talk about i'm
gonna call you out because we haven't
really talked about this yet before
he already knows right i don't i kind of
think so now
what screensaver photo did you have on
your phone when i was a
sophomore freshman sophomore in college
i think you were in eighth grade
um okay three beautiful usc
football players they were very i think
they're
like juniors or seniors in college they
were
looking out into the football field in
like a sexy manner and
they were holding their they were they
had they had the black
paint like the productive voice you're
using the
the football paint on them and i didn't
even know this at the time but she like
was obsessed with this photo and if this
photo did go viral for a hot second
because it was just showing it went
viral on tumblr which if you know
viral you know it popped off for a
minute
i used to love it made that her
screensaver photo right and so i'll just
cut to like
what i was dealing with i was seeing
this guy at the time who ended up being
like my long-term
boyfriend but he had just stopped
playing football i have to
i have to say it from school okay so
scarlett doesn't know that sophia
is talking to one of the football
players i did in the past i
absolutely had no idea this is the best
thing ever no no i want to say i want to
say
okay so i need to say it
so it's podcast obviously
i was i was looking at my phone and then
sophia
wanted to bring her what boyfriend no it
wasn't like
it was like a thing like exclusive that
kind of stage
one of the many stages of dating and um
she brings him home he walks in
and i'm like i just clicked my phone on
and i look at my screensaver for a
second like oh
and then i look up bam
same man on my phone
is staring at me right now
oh at least i i i it was a movie scene
it was like and she was quiet the entire
dinner i'm like what's wrong with this
girl it's like the loudest person in the
room
it's because so much drool was falling
out of her mouth that she couldn't i
wouldn't
realize i couldn't even eat i couldn't
even eat it was like the first time it
was me and my family and i remember
scarlett just wasn't saying that i was
like what's wrong with her and i didn't
find this out until i think sistine told
me
or she showed me scarlett's phone she
goes look at she has
you're now it was like the boyfriend at
the time on her screensaver
so so weird someone put a leash on me
i think being the youngest you have a
lot of advantages like because you get
to pick
which sister you need for what things i
absolutely
love what would you go to sophia for um
yes girl what would you go from i
usually
go to sofia when you used to like no no
growing up when i had like a lot of like
insecurities about how i
looked and i i just like i hated i hated
a lot because a lot of things on my face
like grew before
like me actually developing so i went
through a very very very awkward stage
and i used to go up to sophia and i
always talked to her about
my looks and everything so if you would
sit me down
give me like a 30 minute speech about
like self-empowerment and everything
and looks wise and she really like
helped my confidence
what about me oh [ __ ] yeah whatever
what about me what about me
you it's are you laughing
texting
before the relationship but like that's
you would help me the only thing
you help me with empowerment i give you
texts
no no you help me you help me with like
no no you also help me with
um i usually rant to you about like
something happening in my friend group
or something like that
and i'm a good listener you help her
socially with my friends and stuff yeah
no you know you're there for me at like
really hard i hope you know that i keep
a hit list
oh no no you do you do you call you
called up your guy friends
you don't think i keep a hit list of
boys i called my boys
and i said we're gonna need to pull up
on this kid right now i'll tell you
right now and i was
oh god i'll tell you right now all three
of us if we don't like
one of you or if i don't like one of you
my two sisters are behind it's like
we're not me no no no but we are guard
dogs
you guys aren't mean it's just you guys
are so protective over me
i feel like a little like your little
cub and you guys are like the both mama
bears and you guys
every time i bring like a like a friend
over or something like that it's
you guys are like she's ready you guys
you guys predict
what happens in the end and it always
happens oh yeah
who gives better romance advice
like i'm scared no no so if you taught
me how to be more like like i saw the
way she was with her like her old
boyfriend's up like she's very like
giddy and like goofy and she taught me
like kind of be like
so how to be like like what are the
dark courses that's what my boyfriend
loves about me how like goofy and like
weird i am
and then you it's more like it's more
like
frisky trying to be more mysterious
i am the worst you know you're not no
you're not i just like
i just we we talk about it sometimes and
then we like end up saying the same
thing sometimes
i think i send scarlet a lot of raw she
tic talks that i need to
tone it down a little bit i i i mean
it's literally the devil and the angel
on skrill's shoulder yeah
because i have said i come guys i come
to you when
i want no judgment and i know i did
something super suspicious
and i'm like oh god i know this is bad
and sophia's gonna tell me this is bad
so i'm gonna go to scarlet cause
scarlet's gonna say
okay honestly caught a fire like that's
what you're right
like you guys are like that's pretty
good like good job this is my role as
all just
i can't say to you no no
usually when sassine like screws up or
something and then like i i then
scream and usually grow up and i'd do
something like worse i would usually go
to sistine because it's more like
it's kind of oh that's the best that's i
love when that happens and then sistine
i don't talk a lot about the sus things
that i do i'm acting like i'm some like
drug dealer you're really don't do that
that's suspicious but when scarlett
would mess up i would go scarlett
oh my god when i was your age i did that
but worse and like
yeah yeah and it just made me feel
better you know it's funny though yeah i
told sophia and she's like
mom face like mom she is the mom america
oh i feel like i'm better with it no no
you're such a
yeah and we're like
because guess what we want to do we are
cool
we're gonna play a game i know what the
game is
it's gonna be what our most viral
youtube video was before scarlet deleted
it
called witch sister
scarlett obviously you're gonna say
which sister we're gonna do sort of
rapid fire
and it's pretty easy so we're going to
ask you a question and you're going to
say
which sister is more likely to and you
can answer yourself as well
oh god we can also answer it we have an
opinion strong label
i think it'd be funny like let's just
let's see how it goes ready
which sister is most likely to get
arrested
for what actually no sophia for what
oh hell yeah for what i would definitely
be me but i don't think so no
not you i think sophia 100 percent i
think for
a 100 stalking which sister is more
sensitive
sistine 100 cancer cancer crier
is most likely to get a tattoo and what
sofia because i've the first step was
like
she got a no she wanted or she always
wanted like a nose piercing and i'm like
experiencing so if you would want
something like
live laugh love on her butt cheek it
would get like a cauliflower
that's like telling me i'm gonna get
infinity you get a cauliflower bush like
on your ankle
vegan i'm not even vegan okay
which sister is most likely to have a
dark side
i know it's me sisty i like it
which sister is more likely to cheat on
their boyfriend
oh oh you guys are really putting me in
a situation
no judgment no judgment i don't know
that after this
i really don't okay fine
[Laughter]
wait wait i really thought you were
going to say sophia me too i thought
you're going to be so shocked can i just
quickly explain it i'm so shocked why
i don't know i feel like i feel like
because you haven't had a
is it because i'm more desperate
i really thought it was going to be
sophia that you said scarlett by the way
just disclaimer i won't cheat on a
boyfriend and i would never have even
thought about it
but i just think because my mind goes in
a hundred different directions and
it's also you're i don't know i feel
like i'm honestly
i guess i'm not a cheater it's most
likely to not
shower for a week sophia true
really okay i i show her every day but
most likely to complain
i love complaining it's my favorite
pastime oh
i know which sister is a little brat
you yeah 100
sophia has like this little like girly
flirty personality yeah
the guy's like am i butch
you have a really good banter with guys
like you get their lingo
and you're funny with it you're on the
spot i'm saying girly flirty
which sister loves when friends cancel
on plans
cysteine that's both i have to say yeah
i think i
hate there's nothing i love more than a
cancellation i know uh is the most
indecisive she's indecisive
yep she can't decide i keep on looking
is most likely to sing but shouldn't
sophia
amen doesn't sing but
i know all these things is most likely
to hook up with an axe
is most likely oh no most obsessed with
how they look in photos
yeah obviously i'm not even upset
you know what scarlet and i both can
unanimously agree that you are the
hardest to take photos i have to agree
with that i can't i can't take photos of
systems i can't it gives me anxiety
honestly
like sistine goes take photos like how
um
it took literally 40 minutes to run
around the house
because she knows that like she likes
the way i take photos and how i
like some of my photos that i post and
then i do it of her
and she was like my photos are so much
better i took a view
the other day and i was like i don't
know if anyone out there can relate to
me
um but i am so hard on myself when i get
a photo taken to me and i think it's so
ugly and then a few months later i look
back and say oh my god that was such a
cute pic
why did i tear my ass apart with that
and then last yeah i agree
last but not least is most likely to
call dibs at people and parties
so physically sophia yeah yeah 100 i
don't see sistine doing that
all right well you just played your
first game on the unwaxed podcast
i don't know all right we're gonna wrap
okay cool
we're gonna wrap up the show with
another unsolicited advice scarlett is
gonna partake in this one again if you
guys want
your questions to be answered make sure
you go to the apple podcast section
go to ratings and reviews please give us
five stars and then leave your question
in the review that you write i'm not
kidding you sophie and i probably check
our ratings reviews every other day we
love
they really want you guys we really
really do so we so appreciate it
and so yeah we're gonna we're gonna read
the first one this is from
619 hawk what's up cool name
this person wrote where do you see each
other in 10 years
what would you like to accomplish great
show can i help you yeah go for it
okay we already discussed what we're
going to see each other
um in 10 years we said that we were all
going to take a trip together
with our somewhat long-term boyfriends
or husbands
and go to like a fun paradise trip
together but
i don't know that's what i say i can't
wait because our mom did this with her
sisters
i can't wait until we all have our
significant other and we're just
all six of us are best just traveling
and enjoying like our late twenties
early thirties then we all because we
always wanna
travel too so if you're the three guys
that we're gonna be taking on the trip
maybe come into our lives sooner than
later because i think we all would love
to go to like bora bora together
that's a great answer sophie do you want
to read the next one yeah so the next
one
is from oh a girl after my own heart
vampire diaries forever
ooh i like you um finally i can look
forward to tuesdays now as the title but
the question is
uh my question i have for you guys is do
you ever struggle with dating because
you want them to be exactly like you i
find myself basically wanting to date
myself and really struggle to see past
dating someone that has a lot of
different personalities than me
oh hold on there's more to the question
and someone she also said
why is ratatouille steen's favorite
movie
which
um for you know what's interesting i
think that everyone's totally different
i think
for me i always like going for someone
that is a bit more similar to me
just because of the way i work in my
mindset but
i feel like you're different scarlett no
me and my boyfriend
right now we're complete opposite yet we
do balance each other out a lot
um but like he also has like some good
qualities that we like find and share at
the same interest but you know it's also
good
to date someone that is not exactly like
you i totally agree
it balances out it makes it more
interesting like not every conversation
is like
oh you like football yeah i like
football too like that's great like no
it's
it's more it's like you guys have more
debates it's more like
i totally agree with that i don't i
think opposites attract i sort of
believe in that
what i i don't care if they're exactly
like me in personality
would i care i think about when we
rephrase it what i look for more
is if they put in the same amount of
effort as i do because i
you know start the conversation or i'll
make the plans or i'll always initiate
and it's almost like a one-woman
show and so that's what i look for
someone that puts an equal
amount of you know entertainment
relationships
and i would like to say ratatouille is
my favorite movie
because it is a classic and it never
gets old and
remy the red chewie is finally getting
his you know fame that he deserves on
tick tock and i'm so excited for
ratatouille the musical
i love you wrote hashtag gratitude
forever vampire diaries forever you are
my soul mate thank you for watching
ratatouille
and we've just concluded our first
episode was scarlett
yeah yeah yeah thank you so much and i
think we should definitely do a part two
because i want to do a one where
we actually record each other and i feel
like i know i want you guys to see me
and i want you guys to see if i look
like sophia or sistine
if you guys really like scarlet who
knows maybe she'll be a regular
on the show yeah why not what what
okay we are so excited to do this again
next week
and let us know rate comment give us
that five star remember we will
not answer your unsolicited advice
unless you write it
in the review section we love you i love
you
bye from all of us here at the show
thanks for staying
on wax be sure to download new episodes
every tuesday on apple podcasts spotify
or podcastone.com
follow your hosts at sophia stallone and
at sistine stallone
and be sure to follow the show at unwax
podcast
your producer is will sterling we'll see
you next week